This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个 i-Heart 播客。绝对真人。在 Look Back at it 播客节目中。从 1979 年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84 年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试着去理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn. Learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《学得痛苦》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。多少男人带着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，去听学吧。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学得痛苦》。2023 年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你在这个特定的测试上做了两次手脚，对吧？我对测试做了一次手脚。这需要一支网络侦探大队才能揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
this is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
这是《陷入爱河的陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《陷入爱河的陷阱》播客。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody and welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners,
我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。经历一些困难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，
old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Here's a question for you. How often do you find yourself thinking about the past? How often do you find yourself daydreaming about your first year at college or that like amazing summer you had five years ago, the start of a relationship, your childhood. In those moments, do you feel happier afterwards or sad that no matter what you do, you can't go back to that time or relive those moments? If you answered sad or if you feel a real deep sense of longing, you may or may not be getting stuck in what I like to call the nostalgia trap, spending more time in the past and in your memory.
老听众，无论你身在世界何处。很高兴你能回来收听另一集节目，当然，我们在此剖析二十岁的心理。这里有个问题想问你。你多久会发现自己在思考过去？你多久会发现自己在白日做梦，想着你在大学的第一年，或者五年前那个棒极了的夏天，一段恋情的开始，你的童年。在那些时刻，你事后会觉得更快乐，还是会感到悲伤，无论你做什么，你都回不到那个时代，也无法重温那些时刻？如果你回答悲伤，或者如果你感到一种真正深层的渴望，你可能正在陷入我喜欢称之为“怀旧陷阱”的困境，把更多的时间花在过去和你的记忆中，
and in those really amazing moments, then in the present and constantly feeling like it was so amazing back then and it's never going to be as good as it was. And I want to talk about it today because I think a lot of us are finding ourselves in that trap these days. Nostalgia is a funny emotion in our 20s because although we are still objectively so young, any person over 30 or 40 would tell you that, there is still this sense that we are living out what most people would call the best years of our lives. You know, there's already this sense of anticipatory nostalgia for these moments that aren't
花在那些真正美好的时刻，而不是活在当下，并且不断觉得过去是那么美好，而且再也不会像以前那么好了。我想今天聊聊这个，因为我觉得我们中的很多人这些天都发现自己陷入了这个陷阱。怀旧在我们二十岁时是一种有趣的情感，尽管从客观上讲我们还很年轻，任何三十岁或四十岁的人都会这么告诉你，但我们仍然有一种感觉，认为我们正在过着大多数人所说的我们一生中最好的时光。你知道，对于这些甚至还
even over yet. But on the other hand, we're also getting to an age where we have enough formative memories and years to look back on and miss. And it can honestly leave us feeling really down about the future and whether it will ever, you know, measure up to the amazing memories that we're going to be able to be able to we've made. Let me say this. Nostalgia can be really good for some things. It can keep us grateful, positive. It can bond us to people who were in those memories and in those moments with us. There is even evidence that it can shield us from negative emotions, but it can also cause us to
没有结束的时刻，已经有一种预期的怀旧感了。但另一方面，我们也到了这样一个年龄，我们有足够形成性的记忆和岁月可以回顾和怀念。说实话，这可能会让我们对未来以及未来是否能够（你知道）比得上我们能够创造的美好记忆感到非常沮丧。让我这样说。怀旧对某些事情真的很好。它能让我们保持感激、积极。它能把我们与那些记忆中和那些时刻与我们在一起的人联系起来。甚至有证据表明它可以保护我们免受负面情绪的影响，但它也可能导致我们
honestly feel quite stuck, to miss out on the present, to just feel a real deep sense of longing and also to not be as optimistic for the future. So in today's episode, I want to discuss why that is. Where does nostalgia really come from? What purpose does it serve? And most importantly, what happens when it begins to take over? There is no doubt, in my mind at least, that this generation is more nostalgic than ever. We see that in the resurgence of movies, TV shows, you know, picking up childhood hobbies as a form of escapism.
老实说，会感到相当困惑，错过当下的生活，只感受到一种真正深层的渴望，而且对未来也不那么乐观。所以在今天的节目中，我想讨论为什么会这样。怀旧到底从何而来？它有什么用？最重要的是，当它开始接管一切时会发生什么？毫无疑问，至少在我看来，这一代人比以往任何时候都更加怀旧。我们在电影、电视节目的复兴中看到了这一点，你知道，把童年爱好作为一种逃避现实的形式。
Why is that the case? and how do we handle this increased level of nostalgia in a healthy way? I am someone who is incredibly sentimental. I romanticize the past probably too much. So I'm in the same boat as you guys. I am a 20-something already feeling like the best years are behind me. And I know that sounds ridiculous, but I've just been having a whole lot of nostalgia recently.
这是为什么呢？我们如何以健康的方式应对这种不断增加的怀旧情绪？我是一个非常感性的人。我把过去浪漫化了，可能有点过头了。所以我跟你们在同一条船上。我是一个二十几岁的人，已经觉得最好的时光已经过去了我身后。我知道这听起来很荒谬，但我最近确实有很多怀旧的情绪。
I think because I've been traveling a lot and I was staying at this like beautiful Airbnb in Bali. And I think because it was such an oasis and my memory. mind was so quiet, I really started reflecting on all the wonderful moments in my life and panicking about maybe not recreating them whilst I'm quite literally in paradise. So I get that it's quite a complex feeling and I just want to discuss the science and of course the psychology behind it and the secret world of nostalgia. I'm really excited to share everything that I've learned with you and to help us all cope a little bit more. Without further ado, let's get into it.
我想是因为我一直在旅行，我住在巴厘岛一个非常美丽的爱彼迎里。我想因为那是一个绿洲，我的记忆。脑子很安静，我真的开始反思我生活中的所有美好时刻，并且恐慌于当我字面意思上在天堂时，可能无法重现它们。所以我明白这是一种相当复杂的感情，我只是想讨论背后的科学，当然还有心理学以及怀旧的秘密世界。我真的很兴奋能与大家分享我所学到的一切，并帮助我们所有人更好地应对。废话不多说，我们切入正题吧。
Let's get our basics down pat to begin with before we dive into why we get stuck in the past. There are two types of nostalgia. There is historical nostalgia and personal nostalgia. So historical nostalgia is a little bit less common and it's nostalgia for a time and a place that you've never been, that you've never existed in even. So if you've ever seen people post,
在深入探讨我们为什么会深陷过去之前，让我们先弄清一些基本常识。怀旧有两种。一种是历史怀旧，一种是个人怀旧。历史怀旧稍微少见一些，它是对你从未去过、甚至从未存在过的时间和空间的怀旧。所以，如果你见过有人发帖
about being born in the wrong generation, the wrong decade. That's kind of an example of historical nostalgia, wanting to return to a time period like the 60s or the 90s or wherever, where people imagine life was better, even though it probably wasn't. The kind of nostalgia that we're talking about today, though, is personal nostalgia. And that is wishing to return to a memory, a time, a moment that you have already experienced yourself.
说自己生错了时代，生错了十年。这有点像历史怀旧的例子，想要回到 60 年代或 90 年代或其他什么时期，人们想象那时生活更好，尽管事实可能并非如此。不过，我们今天要讨论的怀旧是个人怀旧。那是渴望回到你已经亲身经历过的记忆、时间和时刻。
When we're talking about this kind of nostalgia, we are talking about an emotional state that combines our memories, that combines some form of sentimentality and pleasure, kind of delight, and getting to experience a small bit of a feeling and a time for ourselves again. But it also has this undertone of melancholy. and pain. It's a positive remembering because we really can only feel nostalgia about good experiences that we enjoyed or felt happy in or that we now see as being valuable. But it's not necessarily
当我们谈论这种怀旧时，我们谈论的是一种情感状态，它结合了我们的记忆，结合了某种形式的感伤和快乐，某种喜悦，并再次体验一点点感觉和当时的自己。但它也带有挥之不去的忧郁和痛苦。这是一种积极的怀旧，因为我们实际上只能对那些我们喜欢、感到快乐或现在认为有价值的美好经历产生怀旧之情。但这不一定是
a positive emotion because in this process of remembering, our nostalgia often stirs up this deeper feeling of longing for a time we can never get back to and therefore feeling quite quite stuck. I think the aching and the subtle sadness, the longing is what really makes nostalgia, nostalgia. Actually, if you were to look at the Greek origins of the word, you would find that it actually comes from two words, Nostos meaning homecoming and algos meaning pain. So in that way, it's also really close to the meaning of the word homesickness, right? I think that that's something that we can all relate to. Nostalgia is, you know, not a sickness, but a longing for a time, and a home that we were once in.
一种积极的情感，因为在这个记忆的过程中，我们的怀旧往往会激起一种更深层的渴望，渴望回到一个我们永远回不去的时间，因此会感到相当困惑。我认为这种隐隐作痛、微妙的悲伤和渴望，才是真正让怀旧成为怀旧的原因。事实上，如果你看一下这个词的希腊语词源，你会发现它实际上来自两个词，Nostos 意思是回家，algos 意思是痛苦。从这个意义上说，它也非常接近“乡愁”这个词的意思，对吧？我认为这是我们都能产生共鸣的一点。怀旧不是（你知道）一种疾病，而是对我们曾经待过的时间和家的渴望。
It's really different from emotions and feelings like happiness, sadness, anger, because they're often so straightforward, right? They're very easy to identify. But nostalgia is nuanced. It's a mix of good and bad, which means that we can find it hard to place. But also it creates this weird relationship where sometimes it can be pleasant when you're not like,
它真的不同于快乐、悲伤、愤怒这样的情绪和感觉，因为它们通常那么直接，对吧？它们非常容易识别。但怀旧是微妙的。它是好与坏的混合体，这意味着我们可能会觉得很难定位。但同时它也创造了一种奇怪的关系，有时当你不像在与朋友叙旧，回想生活中的一段美好时光时，它是愉快的。但另一方面，当你走得太远时，你会被这些关于时间流逝、岁月悄然溜走、关于幸福、恐惧和害怕的真正存在主义焦虑所淹没。那么我们为什么会真实地感受到这种情绪呢？它的目的是什么？我想这是今天最大的问题。怀旧部分是由一种叫做“玫瑰色回忆”（Rosy Retrospection）的东西引起的。倾向于把过去回忆得比实际经历的更美好，基本上“玫瑰色回忆”这个词来自于戴上玫瑰色
you're reminiscing with a friend, you're thinking back on a really nice time in your life. But then on the flip side, when you go too far, you get overwhelmed by these really existential anxieties about time passing, about the years slipping by, about happiness and dread and fear. So why do we actually feel this emotion? What is its purpose? I think that's the biggest question of the day. Nostalgia is in part caused by this thing called Rosie Retrospection. The tendency to recall the past more positively then it was actually experienced basically the word rosy retrospection comes from putting rose-coloured
眼镜。我一直在思考这个问题，以及我多久会陷入这种虚假或不正确的记忆中。就在最近，我和老朋友萨姆叙旧，我们在大学时关系非常非常铁，我们只是在萨里山的咖啡馆一边喝咖啡一边讲着“想当年”的故事，回想着我们生活中的那些时光。当然，（你知道）我们没有去想我们压力极大、心碎、社交焦虑的时候，或者（你知道）我们喝太多酒或者跟别人打架的时候。我们只想着美好的事情。我们只能真正专注于笑声和美好的回忆。
glasses on. I think about this all the time and how often I fall into this form of false or incorrect remembering. Just recently I caught up with my old friend Sam who I was really, really close to at uni and we were just telling, you know, like stories about the good old days over coffee in Surrey Hills and thinking about those times in our lives. And of course, you know, we weren't thinking about the times when we were super stressed or heartbroken or socially anxious or when, you know, we drank too much or we were in fights with people. We only thought about the good things. We only could really hone in on the laughter and the positive memories.
甚至当我们在某种程度上（就像）我要离开的时候，我觉得，哇，那真的非常好，回想起所有这些时光，我有点像是在反省自己。我说，嗯，其实并不全是那样的。我知道事实并非完全如此，但无论我怎么努力，我都记不清很多细节了。这就是玫瑰色回忆。之所以会发生这种情况，是因为我们的大脑已经适应了（如果在情感上没有特别的用处）随着时间的推移，把不好的回忆过滤掉。如果你看过电影《头脑特工队》，里面有一个场景，快乐情绪基本上说，哦，我们不需要这些记忆，这些不好的记忆。我打算把它们扔掉，因为（你知道）反正拥有更多快乐的记忆总比悲伤的记忆要好。那是电影，但这确实也是会发生的事情。这有助于我们保持更积极的自我意识，这正是我们想要的。所以在某种程度上，怀旧可以阻止我们回味所有糟糕和可怕的时光，让我们专注于美好时光。我认为当我们开始思考创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）时，这个理论确实变得有点复杂，因为在那些无法解决的情况下，人们只关注负面记忆和强烈的创伤。那是另一集的内容了。但同样地，2014 年发表的一篇研究论文也表明，基于这种玫瑰色回忆原则，怀旧在精神上、认知上和情感上可以起到保护作用，因为它可以产生我们可以主动调动的温暖、有趣、模糊的感觉。所以当然，怀旧有时是由气味、电影、歌曲或回到你曾经住过的城市所触发的，但我们也可以刻意唤起它。因此，当我们经历孤立时期或者事情对我们来说不太顺利时，
And even when we were kind of like, when I was leaving and I was like, wow, that was really, really nice. And thinking back on all these times, I kind of like was calling myself out a bit. I was like, well, it wasn't all like that. And I know that it wasn't all like that, but no matter how how I try, I can't really remember many of those details. That is rosy retrospection. The reason this happens is because our brain has adapted to kind of weed out the bad
怀旧就像是一种精神时间旅行。正如一位研究人员所建议的那样，它也有助于让我们感觉更有掌控感。让我解释一下。片刻。所以，如果例如，（你知道）你刚刚经历了一次糟糕的友谊破裂，你觉得在工作中真的很卡壳，你觉得在生活中卡壳了，很多这些情况都是你无法控制的。但当你刻意调动旧记忆时，它们是在你的控制之中的，因为它们已经发生了。你知道会发生什么。你知道它们会引发什么感觉。那是一种积极的感觉。所以它有助于你调节你的情感体验。想想为什么我们在葬礼或毕业典礼上会如此追忆往昔。
memories over time if they don't particularly serve us. If you've ever seen the movie Inside Out, there's the scene in which the emotion, joy, basically is like, oh, we don't need these memories, these bad memories. I'm just going to get rid of them because, you know, it's kind of better to have more happy memories than sad memories anyway. That's a movie, but it's also something that does really happen. This helps us maintain a more positive sense of self, which is what we want. So nostalgia on some level can stop us reminiscing on all the bad and terrible times and keep us focused on the good times. I think this theory does get a little bit complicated when we start thinking about PTSD because in those insolvenous.
是的，很明显，背景是一件事情的结束，但是，（你知道）事情的结束是很刺痛的、痛苦的，而且是超出我们控制的，但我们可以通过思考从那次经历中获得的所有美好事物来减轻这种刺痛，并保护自己免受其主要冲击，用我们的怀旧来阻止我们最终真正陷入悲伤之中。如果你想要一项支持这一点的研究。有一位作家，杨博士，几年前对人们进行了一系列实验。他发现，当他的研究中的参与者被要求回忆他们生命中一段非常美好的时光时，
instances, people only focus on their negative memories and their intense trauma. That is just a whole other episode. But on a similar note, there was a research paper published back in 2014 that also suggests that based on this rosy retrospection principle, nostalgia can be mentally, cognitively, emotionally protective because of the warm, fun, fuzzy feelings that it produces and that we can voluntarily tap into. So of course, nostalgia is sometimes triggered by a smell or a movie or a song or returning to like a city that you used to live in, but we can also call on it deliberately. And so when we're going through periods of isolation or things are just kind of not working out for
他们被鼓励去怀旧，与被要求只考虑未来的人相比，他们对微弱电流的疼痛或刺痛的感知要小得多。所以这几乎就像是坐在过去的记忆中，回到那个时代，阻止了你感受到现在的痛苦。你知道这听起来像什么吗？这听起来像是怀旧可能是一种逃避现实的形式。这是我们将自己与生活拉开距离的一种方式。另一个解释可能来自这个特定怀旧心理学领域的最大学者。她的名字叫克里斯蒂娜·巴肖博士。我非常喜欢她对这方面的看法，
us, nostalgia acts as a sort of mental time travel. And so as one researcher suggests, it also helps us feel like we are more in control. Let me explain that. for a moment. So if for example, you know, you've just had an awful friendship breakup, you're feeling really stuck in your job, you're feeling stuck in life, a lot of these circumstances are beyond your control. But when you consciously tap into your old memories, they are within your control because they have already happened. You know what to expect. You know what feeling they're going to elicit. And that is a positive one. So it helps you regulate your emotional experience. think about why we reminisce so much at funerals or graduations.
因为我以前从来没有这样想过。但在“关于心理学”播客上，如果你厌倦了我的播客，这是另一个很棒的心理学播客，她接受了采访，并解释了怀旧如何帮助我们统一自我意识。它有助于统一我们过去的自己和现在的自己，并在我们不同的自我版本之间建立这种契合或连续性。我从来没有这样想过，怀旧可能是一种身份保护的形式，但这是很有道理的，对吧？如果我们从来不思考我们过去是谁，那些造就了今天的我们的记忆，我们是什么样的人，快乐的时光，我想作为人我们会变得更加肤浅，而且也会有点迷失，因为我们无法
Yes, obviously, it's like the context is the end of something, but, you know, the end of something stings and it hurts and it's out of our control, but we can lessen that sting by thinking about all the good things that have come from that experience and shielding ourselves from the brunt of it, using our nostalgia to stop us getting really bogged down in the grief in the end. if you want a study that kind of backs this up. There was this author, Dr. Yang, who conducted a series of experiments on people a few years back. And he found that when participants in his study were asked to reminisce on a really beautiful time in their life,
体会到过去的自己是如何处理某种情况的，或者是什么造就了我们。关于我们为什么会经历怀旧的最后一个理论是，能够回顾过去的记忆让我们有机会与他人建立联系。就像我告诉你们的，我和一个老朋友聚会的这个例子。我们挖掘了那些让我们感觉如此美好的共同经历，它让我们有机会真正巩固一段旧的羁绊。但它也可以帮助我们解决问题。就像过去有很多知识和信息一样，
they were encouraged to be nostalgic, they were less likely to perceive the pain or the sting of a small electric current versus people who were asked to just think about the future. So it was almost like sitting back in the memories of your past, going back to that time, stopped you from feeling the pain of the present. And you know what that sounds like to me? That sounds like nostalgia may be a form of escapism. It is a way to distance ourselves from our lives. Another explanation comes from possibly the biggest academic in this specific domain of nostalgia psychology. Her name is Dr. Christine Barchow. And I love what she has to say about this
而怀旧是我们挖掘这些知识和信息以造福当前自我、造福当前人际关系、造福当前精神状态的方式。所以，是的，有一些解释，其中大部分是好的，或者至少表明了当我们这样看时，怀旧是如何发挥一定功能的。不过，非常有趣的是，正如我在开头提到的，尽管有所有这些好处，但研究人员和心理学家提出了很多建议，即这一代人正在经历比以往任何时候都更多的怀旧。因此，他们比以往任何时候的其他几代人都更依赖它的功能和效用来进行情感保护和社会联系。
because I've never thought about it in this way before. But on the speaking of psychology podcast, which is another amazing psychology podcast, if you're sick of mine, she was interviewed and she explains how nostalgia helps unite our sense of self. It helps unite who we were before and who we are now and create this like a line or sense of continuity between the different versions of ourselves. I have never thought about it in that way that nostalgia may be a form of identity preservation, but it makes a lot of sense, right? If we never thought about who we were in the past, the memories that have made us who we are today, what we were like, the happy times, I think we would be a lot more shallow as people, and also a little bit lost because we aren't
从流行文化的角度来想想这一点。去年，我们看到《芭比》打破了有史以来几乎所有的票房纪录。现在，好莱坞正在发行
able to tap into how our past self-treated a situation or what makes us. The final theory about why we experience nostalgia is that being able to look back at old memories gives us the opportunity to connect with others. Like I was telling you, this example of me, meeting up with an old friend. We tapped into those joint experiences that we felt so funly about and it gave us a chance to really reinforce an old bond. But it can also help us problem solve as well. Like there is a lot of knowledge and a lot of information in the past.
一堆基于童年怀旧、童年电视节目、物品、过去事物的电影。我们都在听 2000 年代初期的复古音乐，我们重新回到了童年的爱好，比如买数码相机、写日记、做剪贴簿或收集小饰品。你知道，甚至在个人层面上，我有很多朋友最近都对我说，哦，还记得美好的旧时光吗？我就是忍不住去想。我们应该
and nostalgia is our way of tapping into those to benefit our current self, to benefit our current relationships, to benefit our current mental state. So, yes, a few explanations, most of them good, or at least showing how nostalgia serves some function when we look at it that way. What's really interesting, and I did mention this at the beginning, though, is that for all of those benefits, there has been a lot of suggestions from researchers and psychologists, that this generation is experiencing more nostalgia than ever. So they are relying on its function and its utility for emotional protection, for social connection, more than any other generation ever has.
回到我们上大学的地方，我们应该回到那些时光。这就是为什么我认为这正在发生，它归结为两个要素。现在这个世界真的很艰难。我们比以往任何时候都压力更大。我们只是被
Think about this in terms of pop culture. Last year, we saw Barbie basically break every single box office record like there ever is. There you are currently, you know, Hollywood is releasing. a bunch of movies based around childhood nostalgia, childhood TV shows, objects, you know, things from the past. We're all listening to like early 2000 throwbacks. We're like getting back into childhood hobbies, like getting digital cameras or journaling or scrapbooking or collecting trinkets. And you know, even on a personal level, I have so many friends who have like said to me recently like, oh, remember the good old days. I just can't stop thinking about it. We should
生活的混乱所淹眠，而且我们非常脱节，所以我们求助于怀旧作为一种保护性防御机制。我们从 2016 年的一项研究中得知，当我们的情绪低落时，我们会更多地体验到怀旧，因为它能让我们感觉更好。它还能
go back to where we went to uni, we should go back to these times. Here's why I think this is happening and it comes down to two elements. The world is just really, really tough right now. We are more stressed than ever. We are more overwhelmed by just like
让我们觉得我们回到了某个熟悉的安全地方。你知道，外面的世界很艰难。也许我们需要更多那样的东西。我们真的很想要过去的安慰。其次，我认为这是疫情的挥之不去的影响，以及我们生命中的那段时光如何让我们陷入了奇怪的悬浮状态几年，当时我们许多人刚开始成年。有一个之前，有一个之后。它确实打乱了我们的时间表和记忆。对于我们许多在二十岁出头经历过这种情况的人来说，现在感觉这十年被分成了两部分。
literally the chaos of living and we're very disconnected so we are resorting to nostalgia as a protective defense mechanism. We know from a 2016 study that we experience nostalgia more when our mood is lower because it helps us feel better. It can also
因此，由于一些研究人员所说的“疫情跳跃”，我们更早地对过去的生活感到怀旧。感觉由于那些因那种疾病和恐惧时期而显然绝对必要的封锁，我们跳过了很多生活和里程碑。因此，我们随后对过去、对疫情前的一段时期更加怀旧。但这也让人觉得，既然我们度过了那一一到两年的时期，期间我们真的没有做任何事情，
leave us feeling like we've returned somewhere safe that is familiar. And you know, it's a tough world out there. Maybe we need more of that. We really want the comfort of the past. And secondly, I think that it's a lingering effect of the pandemic and how that whole time in our lives put us in a weird limbo state for a few years when a lot of us were just starting out as adults. There was a before and there was an after. And it really kind of threw a spanner in the works of our timelines and our memories. And for many of us that experienced that in our early 20s, it kind of feels like this decade is now split into two parts.
以至于我们突然停止了所有让我们体验青春和快乐的事情，并被直接推入了成年世界。你对之前的那段时间感到更加怀旧。希望这说得通。希望你能对此产生共鸣。但这可能会产生问题，因为虽然感到怀旧可能是本能的，可能在这些情况下实际上非常有益，并且正在保护我们免受某种
So we are feeling nostalgic a lot sooner for what life was before. because of what some researchers are calling the pandemic skip. Feeling like we skipped a lot of our life and our milestones because of those lockdowns that were obviously absolutely necessary because of that period of disease and fear. And so we are consequently more nostalgic for the past for a time before the pandemic. But it also feels like because we lived through that like one two year period where we weren't really doing anything,
负面精神状态的影响，但它绝对可以走得太远。正如我之前所说，它绝对可以成为一种逃避现实的形式。这就是我从你们这些听众那里听到很多的。前几天我听到了这样一个故事。他说，我甚至不想再出去了。就像，我为什么还要继续过这种生活？当我以前的回忆如此美好时，为什么我要投资新的记忆？
that suddenly we like put a stop to everything that was. making us experience our youth and our joy so much and kind of were pushed straight into the adult world. You feel more nostalgic for that time before. Hopefully that makes sense. Hopefully you can resonate with that. But this can create problems though because whilst feeling nostalgic, maybe instinctual, maybe in these circumstances is actually quite beneficial and is protecting us from some
我们来聊聊这个，因为这不是生活的方式。你只有一次生命。我觉得我们都想活在当下。我们该怎么做？我们如何打破怀旧陷阱？在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。
kind of negative mental state. It can definitely go too far. it can definitely become, as I said before, a form of escapism. And that is what I've been hearing a lot from you guys, from the listeners. I had this story from someone the other day. He was like, I don't even want to go out anymore. Like, why would I keep living this life that I have? Why would I invest in new memories when my old memories are so good?
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等对话，回顾实践中的那些伪科学，
Let's talk about it because that is no way to live your life. You only get one of them. I feel like we all want to be more present. How can we do that? How can we break out of the nostalgia chat? We're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
以及主导健康产业的过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些困难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the in-practice. and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。那是 T-W-O-Persent。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在 Look Back at it 播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett.
我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，他滔滔不绝地谈论 80 年代的毒品。澄清一下，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为毒品。我可以一整天都在谈论毒品，但为了让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论毒品的第二集了。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
所以我开始看到这里有一条主线。我们现在也把“艾滋病”摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。欢迎收听我的新播客《学得痛苦》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将我十多年来在心理健康领域的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于我们
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple, podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we
没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西，而我们还在追逐它，我们不知道什么时候才算够了，因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的比赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要？
don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同的信任级别。我希望你真正成为一个好人。和我凯尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《学得痛苦》中，就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure,
打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索《学得痛苦》并立即收听。2023 年，前单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于父亲身份丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。
and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
这开始了长达数年的法庭斗争以证明真相。你在这个特定的测试上做了两次手脚，对吧？我对测试做了一次手脚。这需要一支网络侦探大队来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
格雷格·亚莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《陷入爱河的陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这还没结束。
Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《陷入爱河的陷阱》播客。俗话说得好，物极必反，即使是好事，也可能很快变成坏事。我们的怀旧也是如此。对我来说，总有一个时刻，它会从追忆往昔、为我和我爱的人创造的所有记忆感到由衷的快乐，转变为疑惑并真正陷入一个相当黑暗的泡泡中：以后还会像这样好吗？以后还会像以前那样吗？答案是：我不知道。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. The saying always goes, too much of anything, even a good thing, can quickly become a bad thing. And the same goes for our nostalgia. There is always a point for me when it switches from reminiscing and feeling really happy about all the memories that I've made with the people that I love. to wondering and getting really stuck in this quite dark bubble of like, is it ever going to get as good as that? Is it ever going to be like it was then? And the answer is like, I don't know.
这个答案是可怕的，因为它相当不确定。这也确实触及了我们很多二十几岁的人都有的一个巨大恐惧。这个十年被描述为我们一生中最好的时光，充满了火花和我们最伟大的时刻。我们越老，它就越可怕，我们与这段时期以及每个人都告诉我们要享受的这些黄金美好年华的脱节感就越强。很难做到不想抓住这一点，不想变得无忧无虑、年轻和充满热情。但我认为这不是一种健康的思考方式。
And that answer is a scary one because it's quite uncertain. It's also really tapping into a big fear that a lot of us 20-somethings have. This decade is depicted as the best years of our lives and full of spark and our greatest moments. the older we get, the more scary it becomes and the more detached we feel from this period and from these like golden amazing years that everyone is telling us to enjoy. It can be hard to not want to hold on to that and to not want to be careless and youthful and enthusiastic. But I don't think that's a healthy way to think.
我不认为认为我们的二十岁是最好的时光是健康的，因为很多研究实际上表明并非如此。这正是我们的怀旧变得适应不良的时候，这意味着有害、适得其反。它让你脱离现实，因为如果你的现在没有过去那么好，既然你可以一直重播已经发生的事情，你为什么还要花更多时间在现在呢？
I don't think it's healthy to think that our 20s are the best that it's ever going to be because a lot of research actually says that it's not. And this is exactly when our nostalgia becomes maladaptive, meaning harmful, counterproductive. It distances you from reality, because if your present isn't as good as the past, why would you want to spend more time there when you can just keep replaying what's already happened?
这是一个循环。你在回忆中花的时间越多，你的现在感觉就越糟糕，这导致你退回到错误中，甚至更多，然后，你知道，这个循环继续开始觉得你的日常生活更糟。而且它永远不会结束。尽管事实上你可能并没有那么准确地记住那些时刻。这就是玫瑰色回忆原则告诉我们的，不管我们多么喜欢
It's a cycle. The more time you spend in your memories, the worse your present feels, which causes you to revert back to mistake, even more and then, you know, the cycle continues to begin to perceive your daily life even worse. And it just never ends. Despite the fact that actually you're probably not remembering those moments all that accurate anyway. That's what the whole principle of rosy retrosy inspection is telling us as much as we like
怀旧，我们真的能相信怀旧吗？这是要记住的关键事情。那些让你怀旧的时光，真的有那么好吗？比你现在的地方好得多？即使它们是，谁又能说它不会再次发生，仅仅因为你处在一个艰难的境地？无论如何，撇开这一点不谈，它阻止了我们，我认为，去适应我们当前的环境，它会让我们感到相当脱节。我有过一个大学朋友，几年前失联了，超级可爱的一个人，非常聪明，但他总是无一例外地
nostalgia can we really trust nostalgia. That is the key thing to remember. The times you feel nostalgic for, were they necessarily that much? better than where you are now. And even if they were, what's to say that it's not going to be like that, again, just because you're in a tough spot. Regardless, moving on from that, it stops us from, I think, trying to make do with what our current circumstances are, and it can leave us feeling quite detached. I had a friend from university that I lost touch with a few years back, super lovely guy, so intelligent, but he was someone who would always without fail,
每当我们叙旧时，他就只想专门谈论我们的大学第一年。甚至在五、六年、七年之后，他还会提起同样的五个记忆或时刻，我们在大学酒吧喝酒，或者我们大家像疯了一样到处跑，我不知道我们在干什么。就是那种搞笑的事情，疯狂的事情。这几乎成了我们之间的一个笑话。我会逗他。我会说，哦，天哪。就像你今天要掏出哪些回忆一样，我等不及要叙旧了。我越老，就越意识到他仍然无法真正放下那些时光。但我认为那些记忆让他回到了一个快乐的地方，他的生活（你知道）没有以前那么好了，所以
when we would catch up, he would just want to talk about specifically our first year of university. Even five, six, seven years on, he would bring up like the same five memories or moments of us drinking at our college bar or the time that we all were like running around and I don't know what we were doing. Just like funny stuff, crazy stuff. And it almost kind of like became a joke between us. Like I would tease him. I was like, oh my gosh. Like which memories are you going to pull out today, like I can't wait to reminisce. And the older I've gotten, the more I've realized that still he's not been able to really let go of those times. But I think that those memories let him get back to a happy place and his life, you know, wasn't as good as it was then. And so
这是一种应对机制。这通常与被称为“彼得潘综合症”的现象齐头并进。彼得潘综合症描述的是那些不想长大或承担责任、不愿接受未来的人。其中一部分原因可能是他们对自己的青春和保持年轻非常迷恋，对过去很着迷。这是慢性怀旧的一个非常极端的后果，但这并不是说我们看不到。我前几天读到的一件有趣的事情是乔治城大学在 2013 年发布的一份报告，
it was a coping mechanism. This often goes hand in hand with a phenomenon known as Peter Pan syndrome. Peter Pan syndrome describes people who don't want to grow up or accept responsibility, accept the future. Maybe an element of that is because they are very infatuated with their youth and staying young and infatuated with the past. It's a very extreme consequence of chronic nostalgia, but it's not like we don't see it. Something interesting here that I read about the other day was a 2013 report released by Georgetown University. which spoke about how Peter Pan syndrome is becoming more common now because of how hard it is to transition into adulthood in recent decades.
其中谈到了彼得潘综合症现在变得越来越普遍，因为近几十年来过渡到成年期是多么困难。你知道，实现经济独立，我认为这是我们所有人都能感同身受的一个领域。这真的很难。比我们父母那一代要难得多。这在某种程度上意味着，在不得不面对现实之前，我们想多当一会儿孩子，哦，是的，（你知道）我可能永远买不起房了。我得付账单。
You know, becoming financially independent, I think that's one domain where we can all relate. It's really hard. It's a lot harder than it was for our parents' generation. And it kind of means that we want to stay a kid a little bit longer before having to face the reality that, oh yeah, you know, I'm probably never going to be able to afford a home. I have to pay bills.
这是一个永无止境的成年责任循环。这可能会让人感觉很舒服一段时间，但我认为我们都知道，有时逃避和压制现实，比如试图，我不知道，制造一种你可以让时钟停止的错觉，（你知道）这种错觉不可避免地会消退，你会留下一个你未必能应对的现实。过多的怀旧带来的最后一个负面影响是，它在我们离开当下之前就将其玷污了。
It's this never-ending cycle of adult responsibilities. That might feel really comfortable for a while, but I think we all know that sometimes avoidance and suppressing reality, like trying to, I don't know, create the illusion that you can stop the clock is, you know, that illusion is inevitably going to fade, and you're going to be left with a reality that you can't necessarily cope with. One final downside of too much nostalgia, it taints the present before we've even left it.
它最终会让我们感到相当存在主义，因为我们太快开始怀念事物了。这就是所谓的预期怀旧，在事情甚至还没有结束之前就开始怀念它。当你还在创造记忆的过程中时，就会感到悲伤和焦虑。就像当你已经在考虑假期将如何结束时，或者你遇到了一个新人、很棒的人，而你已经在考虑分手会有多糟糕。
And it can end up making us feel quite existential because we start missing things too soon. This is this idea called anticipatory nostalgia, missing something before it's even over. Feeling sad and anxious whilst you are still in the process of making the memory. Like when you're already thinking about how the holiday is going to end, or you meet someone, new and amazing and you're already contemplating how awful the breakup is going to be.
这最终会让我们产生一种存在主义的感受，因为我们开始过早地怀念事物。这就是所谓的“预期性乡愁”的概念——在事情甚至还没结束时就开始怀念它。在制造回忆的过程中，你就会感到悲伤和焦虑。就像你已经在考虑假期将如何结束，或者你遇到了一个全新而了不起的人，而你已经在设想分手的痛苦会有多大。
Like you move into a new house, you're already picturing moving out. That's a personal one. I literally had that thought recently when I moved. I was like, wow, I wonder what it's going to be like to pack up this place. And I was like, that's really not healthy because I'm already feeling sad for a moment that I haven't, in a period of time that I haven't even experienced yet. And it can honestly feel like time is slipping away. What can we do about that?
就像你搬进一栋新房子，你已经在想象搬出去的情景了。这是很私人的经历。我最近搬家时就真的有这种想法。当时我想，哇，不知道收拾这个地方会是什么感觉。然后我想，这其实很不健康，因为我还在体验一个还没经历过的时间段，就已经开始为一个我还没经历过的事情感到难说。老实说，这会让人觉得时间在流逝。我们对此能做些什么呢？
Where is the balance? What is the line between feeling reflective and appreciating your happy memories and falling into an obsession with the past and also falsely believing that that is the best it will ever be? Well, I've got four tips for you guys today to kind of get back to the bright side of nostalgia and break out of the nostalgia trap. Firstly, give yourself space for nostalgia and embrace it. This may sound counterintuitive, but every emotion has a place. and serves a function. Otherwise, they wouldn't exist. I believe that fully. And we know that nostalgia is actually quite useful in certain situations. So we don't want to ban ourselves from ever dipping into the past. Also, because the more you deny something, usually the stronger it gets.
平衡点在哪里？反思并珍惜快乐的回忆与陷入对过去的执念、甚至错误地认为那是人生巅峰之间的界限是什么？今天我为大家准备了四个小建议，帮助大家重回怀旧的光明面，跳出怀旧的陷阱。首先，为怀旧留出空间并拥抱它。这听起来可能有些违背直觉，但每种情感都有它的位置，并且发挥着作用。否则它们就不会存在。我完全相信这一点。而且我们知道，怀旧在某些情况下确实非常有用。所以我们不想禁止自己去回忆过去。另外，通常你越是抗拒某事，它的力量就会越强大。
That's the whole principle behind avoidance. It's about balance, but more than that, leaning into your nostalgia rather than fighting against it because that just makes it stronger. A few ways that we can do this. Firstly, use this tactic that I like to call the acknowledge and divert tactic. This basically involves, you know, when you feel nostalgia coming up, give yourself two to five minutes to feel it to really be like, yeah, that was such a great time. I really miss those people. I really miss those memories. And then transition into doing something else that is kind of aligned with nostalgia. So, for example, swap out thinking about the past,
这就是回避原则背后的全部原理。关键在于平衡，但更重要的是，顺应你的怀旧情绪，而不是与之对抗，因为对抗只会让它更强烈。我们可以通过以下几种方法来做到这一点。首先，使用我喜欢称之为“承认与转移”的策略。这基本上意味着，当觉察到怀旧情绪涌上心头时，给自己两到五分钟的时间去感受它，真正地去想：是的，那真是一段美好的时光，我真的很想念那些人，我真的很想念那些回忆。然后，转而去做好友这种与怀旧契合的其他事情。例如，用思考未来取代思考过去，
we're thinking about the future. I also like to swap out longing for the past with gratitude. Like, wow, it's amazing that I got to have those experiences rather than I wish I was still there. But also keeping a running list of things that I'm excited for in the future. And every time I feel myself getting sad about the past, and, you know, sad about the memories that exist there, I like to add myself, add something else to that list.
或者用感恩取代对过去的留恋。比如，哇，太棒了，我曾拥有过那些经历，而不是“我真希望自己还在那里”。同时，列一个我所期待的未来的清单。每当我发现自己开始为过去感到难悲，或者为那里存在的记忆感到难过时，我就会在那个清单上再添上一笔。
So I always think about like when I get my first dog, how exciting is that going to be? When I get to decorate my own home that I own, you know, I think about the next time I get to go on vacation. And it positions myself to think positively about my future memories and their capacity to be amazing rather than only focusing on what comes before. Adding to that, I would also say create events, book trips, put things in the calendar to look forward to so that, feeling nostalgia is not the only thing that comes up. Watch just how this works, wonders. I think hope and anticipation is such a beautiful antidote to a lot of things, not just nostalgia.
所以我总是会想，当我得到第一只狗的时候，那会有多激动人心？当我能装饰属于自己的房子时，我会想，我下一次去度假是什么时候。这让我能够积极地看待未来的记忆以及它们变得精彩的潜力，而不是只关注过去发生的事。除此之外，我还想说，去创造活动、预订旅行、在日历上记下值得期待的事情，这样怀旧就不会成为唯一涌上心头的情绪了。看看这招有多神奇吧。我认为希望和期待是许多事情的绝佳解药，不仅仅是对抗怀旧。
Secondly, I would say probe, what about those times, makes you so reminiscent and happy. Is the reason you feel nostalgic for that time when you lived with your friends in that big house or when you saw your friends every day or when you were at uni or at college or in high school? Is it because there is something? contained in those memories that you now feel like you are missing. Is it because you are lonelier now? Is it because you feel isolated? It's really important to remember that often your nostalgia is indicating to you something that you don't feel like you currently have. Something about your current circumstances that needs to shift, whether you need more community, more people, more, I don't know,
其次，我想说，去探究一下，过去的那段时光里，究竟是什么让你如此怀念和快乐。你之所以对那段时光感到怀旧，是因为你和朋友们住在那栋大房子里，还是因为你每天都能见到朋友，或者是你在上大学、读高中？是因为那些记忆中包含着某种你现在觉得已经失去了的东西吗？是因为你现在更孤独了吗？是因为你觉得被孤立了吗？这一点真的很重要，因为你的怀旧情绪往往在向你暗示，你觉得目前缺少了什么。你目前的环境中有什么需要改变的，不管是你需要更多的社区、更多的人、还是我不知道的……
hope, like more work-life balance, more purpose, whatever it is. What we feel nostalgic for is usually what we lack, because you can't really miss something if you still have it. And the same goes for a lot of things, like feeling nostalgic, not just for the times when you had a lot of friends, but feeling nostalgic for a free, a time of a lot of freedom or a time when you're experiencing a lot of love. The root of nostalgia is longing. So by fulfilling that aspect that we miss in our lives by addressing it, normally the nostalgia tends to fade. On that note as well, remember that there are cognitive biases at work here that you can't see that are sometimes causing you to think about things and think about things in the past as being better than they were.
希望，比如更多的工作与生活平衡、更多的目标，无论是什么。我们所怀念的通常是我们所缺乏的，因为如果你还拥有着某样东西，你是不会真正去怀念它的。许多事情也是如此，比如怀念的不仅是曾经拥有很多朋友的时光，还有怀念充满自由的时光，或者经历过很多爱的时光。怀旧的根源在于渴望。因此，通过解决并满足我们生活中缺失的那部分，怀旧情绪通常就会逐渐消退。另外，还要记住，这里存在着你看不见的认知偏差，它们有时会让你把过去的事情想得比实际更好。
If you need a little bit of a reality check, try and fill in the gaps, not necessarily just to focus on the negatives, but make sure that you're not ignoring the nuances of your memories. I see this a lot with people who have just gone through a breakup. Normally like two to three months down the line, they'll really start reminiscing. And they'll really start being like, oh, but I really like, he made me feel amazing. She was so kind.
如果你需要一点现实的检验，试着填补这些空白，不一定是为了只关注负面因素，而是要确保你没有忽视记忆中的细微差别。我在刚经历分手的人身上经常看到这一点。通常在两到三个月后，他们真的会开始追忆往事。他们会开始说：“哦，但我真的很喜欢他，他让我感觉好极了。她人太好了。”
She was so smart. Remember that time that we went and picnicked and that beautiful thing happened. And it's like, that is 0.001% of that experience. And that is your mind trying to keep the positive memories afloat to block out the darkness. When you really start to fill in the gaps of those experiences, and when, you know, in these situations, I encourage people to be like, okay, but tell me, tell me a negative memory.
她太聪明了。还记得我们去野餐的那次，发生了那么美好的事情吗？这就像是整个经历中的0.001%。而这正是你的大脑在努力让积极的记忆浮现，以屏蔽黑暗。当你真正开始填补这些经历的空白时，当你在这种情况下鼓励自己说：“好吧，但请告诉我，告诉我一个消极的记忆。”
Tell me a negative experience. The nostalgia also starts to fade because I think you just, you see things as clearer and more realistically, and you stop glamorizing them. Some people can end up falling into quite a, what they call a nostalgic depression, which isn't a specific DSM diagnosis, but basically describes a. pattern of symptoms surrounding depression that are mainly focused on feeling overwhelmingly dissatisfied about the present compared to the past. And I'm not sure how common this is, but if you truly can't find a way to live in the
“告诉我一个不好的经历。”怀旧情绪也会开始消退，因为我觉得你会把事情看得更清楚、更现实，并不再将它们美化。有些人最终可能会陷入所谓的“怀旧抑郁”，这不是一个具体的DSM诊断，但它基本上描述了一组与抑郁相关的症状模式，主要表现为对与过去相比的现实感到压倒性的不满。我不确定这种情况有多普遍，但如果你真的找不到方法活在
moment, if you're feeling increasingly deflated, exhausted by life, not wanting to try, I think that's also where more help is required. And a therapist might suggest some things for you to do like mindfulness or focusing on intentional nostalgia rather than spontaneous nostalgia, which basically means, like we said, before giving yourself a dedicated time to feel nostalgic and to let that inform your next steps, to feel grateful for the past, to connect with others, but then also refocus on the future, refocus on, you know, what's going on right now. I want to say this for the people who really struggle with nostalgia.
当下，如果你感到越来越沮丧、被生活榨干、不想去尝试，我想这也是需要更多帮助的时候。治疗师可能会建议你做一些事情，比如正念，或者专注于有意识的怀旧，而不是自发的怀旧，这基本上意味着，就像我们之前所说的，给自己一段专门的时间去感受怀旧，并让它为你的下一步行动提供参考，对过去心怀感激，与他人联系，但随后也要重新聚焦于未来，重新关注当下发生的事情。我想把这段话送给那些真正与怀旧做斗争的人。
you would be blown away by how many people feel exactly the same way as you do, who wish for a time that has passed, who wonder if it will ever be good as it was before, who, you know, watch those golden memories and feel really sad that it's over. But here's the thing, when you ask yourself, is it going to get better, it will, there is your answer. And here's how I know why. I know that from a study that was published in 2018 in this book called The Happiness Curve. This study in this book in general looked at happiness over our lifetime. We normally reach peak happiness around our mid-20s to 30s. So that's basically where most of us are at right now. We're kind of just past or reaching or close to reaching peak happiness. Then it kind of starts to plateau and decrease
你会惊讶地发现，有那么多人和你的感受一模一样，他们渴望逝去的时光，想知道生活是否还能像以前一样美好，那些珍视金色记忆并为之结束感到无比难过的人。但关键是，当你问自己“生活会变好吗”，答案是肯定的，这就是你的答案。我是怎么知道的呢？我是从2018年出版的一本名为《幸福曲线》的书中的一项研究中了解到的。这本书中的研究总体考察了我们一生的幸福感。我们在20多岁到30岁左右通常会迎来幸福的巅峰。所以这基本上是我们大多数人目前的状态。我们刚刚越过、正在经历或接近幸福的巅峰期。然后它开始趋于平稳并下降
after our 30s, which is when we tend to get more nostalgic. This is when I think we start to think that the best years are behind us. And just when we lose hope in our 40s, in our late 40s, look at that, things start picking up again. And by the time we're in our late 50s, early 60s, we are often the happiest that we have ever been. And our nostalgia just becomes gratitude. And it goes hand in hand with the good experience. that we continue to have. So, that myth that this is the best years of your life? Not true.
在30岁之后，这就是我们往往变得更加怀旧的时候。我认为正是在这个时候，我们开始认为最好的日子已经过去了。就在我们在40岁、40多岁快结束时失去希望时，看呐，事情又开始好转了。等到我们快50岁、60岁出头的时候，我们往往会迎来一生中最快乐的时光。我们的怀旧也变成了感恩。它与我们不断拥有的美好经历相辅相成。所以，所谓的“这是你一生中最好的几年”这个神话？并不真实。
Seems you've got a little while longer before that happens. And in the meantime, you're still going to make really, really, really good memories. I know it feels like a long time away, especially if you're trapped in the nostalgia cycle right now, but you can't feel nostalgic forever. Eventually there will be, eventually you kind of start to realize like, ha but now I'm feeling nostalgic for a time when I was nostalgic about a time when I was nostalgic like if you kind of get where I'm coming from it's like you're still making memories
看来距离那一天到来你还有一段时间。在此期间，你仍然会创造出非常非常美好的回忆。我知道这感觉像是很久以后，特别是如果你现在正陷入怀旧的循环中，但你不可能永远怀旧下去。最终会有那么一天，你会开始意识到：“哈，但现在我开始怀念我曾经怀念过去的那个时间了”，如果你能理解我的意思的话，这就好比你仍在创造记忆
in the process that you're going to be nostalgic for in three six months and so your brain kind of starts to teach itself like hmm maybe it's better to focus on these now so that we have more to feel thankful for in the future and it will eventually I think start to do some of the work for you and break you out of the cycle. That is the most important thing that I think, actually the best way to finish out this episode is to remind you fully wholeheartedly that right now, these days that you are living,
在这个过程中，三六个月后你会为之怀旧，所以你的大脑开始自我训练：“嗯，也许现在专注于这些事情会更好，这样我们在未来就有更多值得感激的事情了。”我想它最终会开始为你做一些工作，帮你打破这个循环。我认为这是最重要的事情，实际上，结束这一集的最好方式是全心全意地提醒你，此时此刻，你正在度过的这些日子，
you will eventually look back on fondly. And even if you don't look back on them fondly, you will find a lesson contained in them. And you will find something in them to remember in some positive or informative light. So just try your best to focus on what's happening around you right now. Even if it's a rough time in your life, it's leading you somewhere bigger. One day this will be a memory to reminisce on when the good times come back around.
你最终都会满怀深情地回想起它们。即便你没有深情地回想起它们，你也会在其中找到包含的教训。你会在其中找到一些东西，在某种积极或有启发意义的光芒下去记住它们。所以，尽你最大努力去关注此时此刻你身边正在发生的事情。即使这是你生命中的艰难时期，它也会引领你走向更广阔的天地。总有一天，当美好时光再度降临，这将是一段可以细细品味的记忆。
I know that the nostalgia trap feels so rough sometimes that it also sometimes feels really nice to live in the past when we already understood everything that was going to happen. but whatever you do, whenever you do, do not base your life on just a few memories. Continue to create fuel and make more so that your future self has more to think about. Your future self has more to feel grateful for. Thank you again for listening to this episode. Thank you to those of you who suggested it. It was a great topic to cover. I feel like the more I speak about it to people around me,
我知道怀旧陷阱有时会让人感觉如此艰难，以至于有时活在过去会感觉非常好，因为那时我们已经懂得了将要发生的一切。但无论你做什么，千万不要只把你的生活建立在少数几段记忆上。继续创造、补充并制造更多回忆，好让未来的自己有更多可想的。未来的自己有更多值得感恩的事。再次感谢收听本期节目。感谢那些建议这个选题的朋友们。这是一个非常棒的主题。我觉得我跟周围的人谈论得越多，
the more people come out of the woodwork and go, oh yeah. I have those existential fears. I have those worries as well. So as always, I think that vulnerability unites us and that vulnerability makes us feel less alone. So I hope that you learn something. I hope that you can take something away and apply it to your own life. If you enjoyed this episode, make sure that you are following along on Apple Podcasts or Spotify. And please feel free to leave a five-star review. It helps the show to grow so much.
就会有越多的人吐露心声并说：“哦，是的。我也有这种存在主义的恐惧。我也有这些担忧。”所以和往常一样，我认为脆弱让我们团结在一起，脆弱让我们感到不那么孤独。所以我希望你学到了一些东西。我希望你能从中有所收获并将其应用到你自己的生活中。如果你喜欢这一集，请确保在Apple Podcasts或Spotify上关注我们。也请随时留下五星好评。这对节目的成长非常有帮助。
and I really appreciate seeing your feedback and hearing from you guys and just knowing, you know, what's going on in your lives, but also what content you want to see, what episodes you want to hear. So if that, if you've got an episode suggestion, if you've got something on your mind, please feel free to DM me on Instagram at that psychology podcast. I would love to hear from you. I would love to hear, you know, what you want us to talk about. So until next time, until we talk soon, stay safe, stay kind. and of course be gentle with yourself.
我真的很感激看到你们的反馈，倾听你们的心声，不仅想知道你们的生活发生了什么，还想知道你们想看什么内容，想听什么节目。所以如果你有节目建议，如果你有什么心事，请随时在Instagram上私信我，账号是that psychology podcast。我很期待听到你们的声音。我很想听听你们希望我们聊些什么。那么直到下次，直到我们再次交谈，注意安全，保持善良，当然，对你自己温柔一点。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
欢迎收听《回看过去》（Look Back at It）播客。1979年对我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the eye heart. radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代那样。84年真是疯狂的一年。我是说，那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难学步》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，
that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was
这些对话在任何地方说其实都不太安全，但你是在跟一位经验丰富的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一身铠甲？它向世界释放出信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就非得这么做。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学步》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲，但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你对这个特定的测试造假了两次，对吗？我造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰奇尼。我的脑子
blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience. in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side
都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《受困于爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《受困于爱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-HartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an I-Hart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们这个奇特的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这就是TWA%（注：ASR原文如此）。这是一个iHeart播客。百分之百真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。